now this looks like an interesting
problem we have this polygon it looks
like a pentagon right over here has five
sides it's an irregular pentagon not all
the sides look to be the same length and
the sides are kind of continued on and
we have these particular exterior angles
of this pentagon and what we're asked is
what is the sum of all of these exterior
angles and it's kind of daunting because
like they don't give us any other
information they don't even give us any
particular angles they don't give you
know they don't start us off anywhere
and so what we can do let's just think
about the step by step just based on
what we do know
well we have these exterior angles and
these exterior angles are all they're
each
they're each supplementary to some
interior angle so maybe if we can
express them as a function of the
interior angles we can maybe write this
problem in a way that seems a little bit
more doable so let's write the interior
angles over here so let's say we have
this we already got to letter we already
got to e so let's call this f
this interior angle f let's call this
interior angle g let's call this
interior angle h let's call this one i
and let's call this one j and so this
sum of these particular extra angles a
is now the same thing a is now the same
thing as 180 minus g because a and g are
supplementary so a is 180
minus g
and then we have plus
b
but b we can write in terms of this
interior angle is going to be 180 minus
h because these two angles are once
again are supplementary we do that in a
new color so this is going to be 180
minus h and we could do the same thing
for each of them c we can write as 180
minus i so plus 180
minus i
and then d we can write
d we can write as 180 minus j
so plus 180 minus j and then finally e
i'm running out of colors e
we can write as 180 minus f
so plus 180
plus 180 minus f and so what we're left
with if we add up all the 180s we have
185 times so this is going to be equal
to
5 times 180 5 times 180 which is what
like 900 and then you have minus g minus
h minus i minus j minus f or we could
write that as minus
minus i'll try to do the same colors g
plus h
i'm kind of factoring out this negative
sign g plus h
do the same colors g plus that's not the
same color
g
plus h
plus i
plus j
plus f
and the whole reason why i did this and
why this is interesting now is that
we've expressed this first thing that we
need to figure out we've expressed it in
terms of the sum of the interior angles
so it's going to be 900 minus all of
this business so this is
this is 900
minus all of this business which is the
sum of the interior angles so this is
the sum
of the interior angles so it seems like
we've made a little progress if we can
at least if we can figure out the sum of
the interior angles and to do that part
i'll show you a little trick what you
want to do is divide this polygon the
inside of the polygon into three
non-overlapping triangles and so we
could do that from any side let me just
say let's let's say they're all
coming out of that side right over there
so there i have divided it let me do
this in a neutral column do it in white
so
so that's one triangle right over here
and then let me make another triangle
just like that so there you go i've
divided into three non-overlapping
triangles and the reason why i did that
the reason why this is valuable is we
know what the sum of the angles of a
triangle add up to
and so to make that useful we have to
express these angles in terms of the
sums or in terms of angles that we can
figure out based on the fact that the
sums of the of the angles or the
measures of an angles in a triangle add
up to 180.
so g is kind of already one of the
angles in the triangle f is made up of
two angles in the triangle so remember f
is this entire angle right over here so
let's let's divide f into two other
angles or two other measures of angles i
should say so let's call it let's call f
is equal to let's say that f is equal to
see we've already gone as high as let's
see abcdefg
h i j we haven't used k yet so let's say
that f is equal to k
plus l it's equal to the sum of the
measures of these two adjacent angles
right over here so f is equal to k plus
l so that that way we've split it up
into the part into angles of these other
triangles and then we can do that with j
as well
we can do that with j as well we can say
because j once again is that whole thing
so we could say that j is equal to
let's see we already used l so let's say
j is equal to m plus n
so j
is equal to m
plus n
and then finally we can split up h
h is up here remember it's this whole
thing let's say that h is the same thing
as o plus p
plus q this is o this is p this is q and
once again i wanted to split up these
interior angles if they're not already
parts of already an angle of a triangle
i want to split them up into angles that
are parts of these triangles so we have
h is equal to o plus p plus q and the
reason why that's interesting is now we
can write we can write the sum of these
interior angles as the sum of a bunch of
angles that are part of these triangles
and then we could use the fact that
those that that for any one triangle
they add up to 180 degrees so let's do
that so this this expression right over
here is going to be g g is that angle
right over here we didn't make any
substitutions so it's going to be g
actually let me write the whole thing so
we have 900 900 minus
and instead of a g well actually i'm not
making a substitution so i can write g
plus instead of an h
instead of an h i can write that h is o
plus p plus q
plus o plus p
plus q
and then plus i
plus i i is sitting right over there
plus i
and then plus j
and i kind of messed up the colors or
the i the magenta will go with i and
then j is this expression right over
here so j is equal to m plus n so plus m
plus n instead of writing a j right
there and then finally we have our f
and f
f we've already seen is equal to k plus
l
so plus k
plus l so once again i just rewrote this
part right over here in terms of these
component angles
and now something very interesting is
going to happen because we know what
these sums are going to be because we
know that g plus k plus o is 180 degrees
they are the measures of the angle for
this first triangle over here for this
triangle right over here so g plus o
plus k is 180 degrees so g
let me do this in a new color so for
this triangle right over here this
triangle right over here we know that g
plus o
plus k is go are going to be equal to
180 degrees so if we cross those out we
can write 180 instead and then we also
know let me see i'm definitely running
out of colors we know that p
for this middle triangle right over here
we know that p plus l plus m is 180
degrees so p
plus l
plus m is 180 degrees so you take those
out and just you say you know that sum
is going to be equal to 180 degrees and
then finally this is the home stretch
here we know that q plus n plus i is 180
degrees in this last triangle
q plus n plus i q plus n plus i is 180
degrees
the that those are those three are also
going to be 180 degrees and so now we
know the sum of the interior angles for
this irregular pentagon it's actually
going to be true for any pentagon is 180
plus 180 plus 180 which is 540 degrees
so that whole thing is 540 degrees and
if we want to get the sum of those extra
angles we just subtract it from 900 so
900 minus 540 is going to be
360 degrees and we are done this is
equal to 360 degrees